bernard vous êtes violemment clasher ce
matin avec jean bessière sur les réseaux
sociaux
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer la
véritable raison alors est ce qu'on peut
voir un petit récap du clash montiel
jean bessière c'est parti il faut
arrêter de polémiquer bon monsieur
messier a fait de la politique on le
sait j'ai tout au fond de commerce mais
si pas du tout et je regarde les choses
telles que les frondeurs enquête sur
tous les plateaux mais c'est pas grave
il a rien sur eux ils savent que vous
êtes pas vous n'aimez pas vidéo bien
qu'à l'époque
c'est vrai que vous sur les plateaux
vous êtes aussi prolixe que baudelaire
sa série à son style à lui un lieu sous
la ceinture de la merde il fait quoi
quand et n'importe quoi je serais vous
franchement vous avez une mangue parole
du gouvernement de la france dans le
domaine dont le maire et vous osez
encore la ramener sur le plateau à être
à votre place je me ferais vraiment
discret un jeu pas répondre à ce
monsieur l'abbé bien sûr intéressant
arrêtons tout ce que je leur réponds
vous jugeront l'année prochaine monsieur
dominé jo mais c'est l'effet reçoit dès
que mr la montée alors aujourd'hui sur
twitter ça a été un massacre
visez un peu les amis à ma chronique du
manis membres de la légion des
volontaires français de lutte contre la
haine me traite de ras jdir c'est que
traiter un arabe de ras et d'un racisme
abjecte cher bernard montiel pas besoin
de vidéo pour que tu sois un gag le plus
abject c'est vous associer un rat arabe
faut vraiment être tordu à ce soir
paraît-il alors eh ben je suis d'abord
je lui avais dit qu'il était un rat
plateau il est vrai que quand on apprend
que ça aux fonctionnaires c'est étonnant
le vois tellement sur les plateaux de
télévision moi aussi je croyais que
c'était un chroniqueur voyez ah ouais
bah oui oui non c'est vraiment n'importe
quoi vous trouvez qu'on le voit crossois
les pâtes aux gens mais sur un bord le
web est sans fond de commerce il va y
traînent partout
non mais ce que je lui reproche surtout
mois il pense ce qu'il veut et je
respecte le public et vous avez vu dire
il est là
musiquele épaules car il s'est plus
riches à champignons ça va aller alors
qu'est ce qui se passe car tu sais je
reste où vous lui reprochez alors
annoncé je trouve choquant c'est que
vous ayez fait ce rapport rade plateau
c'est une expression avec l'arabe ça
c'est dingue ça s'est décidé à vous ça
alors c'est vos idées à vous c'est pas
beaucoup dans ses bouquins effet la cdc
c'est quand même extraordinaire c'est
que je le en fait je ne suis jamais
autant animalisés que par les
progressistes comme vous vous avez votre
ami bela tarr qui m'avait traité de
chameau vous me réservez vous me traitez
doha ça pose pas de problème et ça
choque personne
d'accord parce qu'en fait quand une
immigration devient française tout et
open bar pour l'insulté et la ravaler
par contre pour tout ce qui concerne la
racaille cathodique la diable ils sont
intouchables vous leur dites juste
bonjour de savères notre métier à part
[ __ ] la merde et raconter d'importants
dons c'est quoi votre métier à part
[ __ ] la merde et n'importe quoi moi je
suis et je suis partie de la division
nord de la haine et de l'exclusion vous
voyez et ça c'est de la cua de la peine
fait la paix nous venons vous faites la
bouffe est des panneaux français de la
peine aux français
non mais je m'adresse pas aux français
si si oui oui mais moi les mois si vous
voulez je représente quand même quelque
chose vous vous raconter quelque chose à
vous dire
alors je vous dis bien sorti même votre
parti ou hibou renchérit août 2010 9
vous voulez mener la liste du
rassemblement national pour vos
élections municipales de 2001 à paris ve
est refusé non ils ont bâti federbusch
attends je termine pas vrai permettez
moi de terminer monsieur rassure
nationale vous refuse de figurer sur la
liste du parti aux élections européennes
en 2009 ainsi qu'aux élections
régionales de 2021 dans l'aisne alors à
mon avis vous êtes adeptes de la théorie
du grand remplacement mais c'est vous
qu'on essaie d'en rêver vous est là pour
terminer mais bien récitée votre fiche
wikipédia genre messia vous êtes le
françois pignon de la télévision et de
la peine quand c'est à dire le grand
dîner de cons but et vous êtes vous vous
êtes le grand flou
vous êtes le grand clown de la télé
parce que vous avez passé seize ans sur
tf1 vous en effet jeté comme un
malpropre c'est vrai vous allez vous
êtes après et après après vous être fait
des heureux en or use est utilisé
surtout les toutes les personnes celles
avec lesquelles vous avez eu des
accointances et peut-être des amitiés
alors j'en rêve en amitié je voulais je
viens de rappeler je viendrai pas trop
la ramener sur ce terrain avoue rudi
c'est parce que vous avez répété son
opinion de la révolte à 90 vous voir
vous traîner sur tous les plateaux nous
raconter votre même dit à l'ats devenez
la salade de la haine ou l'exclusion
vous aimez rusé a encore été à d'aboyer
démographique ne rame pas vous dîtes
vous n'êtes qu'un fossile télévisuelle
disparaître je vous dis cc c'est bien
que vous cherchez à faire de l'audimat
en m'attaquant honneur c'est vous qui
cherchez
c'est vous qui avez pas pensé sur
twitter un ratio surtout le fait à
chaque fois alors qu'un tweet et en
premier moi j'étais j'ai twitté
d'extrême ce qui s'est passé j'ai rien
tweeted mal et alors il est clair il dit
ouais j'ai rembarré montiel mais les
malades
vous savez pourquoi je vous respecte pas
moi m'sieur experts non non non je vous
rassure il ya toujours elle ne respecte
pas votre méthode parce que je respecte
plus un militant de la france insoumise
ou même de la république en marche a
même gardé jeou avait rejeté la 26ème
rouleur qui affiche la couleur parce
qu'on sait à quoi s'en tenir
plutôt qu'un type qui vient expliquer
qu'il est chroniqueur indépendant
impartial
ou alors que vous êtes en fait à un faux
nez de la république en marche on côté
rose et joseph yam
je vais défendre bernard est ouverte il
a toujours il extrêmement honnête il a
toujours dit qu'il s'entendait très bien
avec quoi le présidentielle s'il s'en
cache pas non on le voit tous les jours
là dessus oui c'est moi qui le vans
nature l'aplomb l'important mais ils
sont cache pas je manque 10 et s&p
parole du gouvernement c'est incroyable
je le fais par web ou cette porte-parole
de douane de fait mais non tu ne seras
lynché désormais de feng d'accord et
c'est ce qui me gêne pas que vous le
croyez de métal centre il ya des gens
qui nous ya des gens qui lui
montiel et messiaen dirait raymond et
huguette de scènes de ménages mais ce
qui est drôle c'est que je normalement
vous devez vous aplatir devant moi parce
que je suis de la diversité aplatir mais
moi l'adversité pas de le dire c'était
moi je suis de la diversité la diversité
que vaut votre courant politique le
progressisme adore cette ds ce devant
laquelle vous prosternez en pareils
faits la politique c'est vrai je vais te
le traverse illusion aplatissez jason
o'mara cola je suis d'accord mais oui
alors vous vous dites partout des
techniciens etc
on s'en fou qu'est ce que vous pouvez
pour besançon français monsieur arrêtez
s'il vous plaît les deux bien vous êtes
pieds nos vertes le roi de l'exclusion
bien sur l'eau en fait je suis dit viser
à vérifier a besoin en ce moment limité
ah oui c'est ça on avait faim dignité
mais déterminé les chéris merci est ce
que vous voulez pas vous dire un petit
mot gentil avant de partir alors qu'il
aille voir sa mère qu'elle vous dis ma
mère oui des te le dis merde votre
bouche c'est pas étonnant non mais c'est
ça ouais vous dit rien ma mère est morte
mais moi je le suis pas votre mère vous
voyez quand elle est morte
allez donc vous disiez ya un instant que
vous ne respectiez bas en tout cas vous
risquez programme est maintenant à jour
hier luzia appréciera en faux cul dans
les couloirs hier il m'a salué très
chaleureusement je trouve ça très sympa
oui je vous ai rendu le 6 mai attendait
ça correct mais moi qui m'a offert une
chance du verset passe à défaire donné
mais c'est très important ça ouais nous
sommes dans un pays civilisé où l'on
pratique me sourit je trouve ça bien
mais c'est pas parce que nous sommes en
désaccord complet ce qu'on va se voit là
on l'a déshabillé c'est aussi bien voilà
on se salue mais ça va mais là vous êtes
ravir la larve aliments
je suis là on peut contourner tous les
mecs qui vont résulter sur twitter on
peut c'est incroyable j'ai tapé leur
profil
on peut alors génération et médiatique
faire génération identitaire les mecs la
france d'abord les étrangers dehors j'ai
regardé vous voulez gens qui m'ont
insulté ce matin moi j'ai regardé les
vôtres bravo j'ai regardé les bourbes
insulté ce matin d'accord à regarnir a
dit le témoin
au nom de la diversité que vous adorez
ah oui des gens de gouarec dans adoré
aussi fort des halles et sur play avant
avant de tenir un même pas un petit mot
gentil genre petit truc mais sachez le
si sympathique en plus mais c'est
toujours un petit chèque de loin comme
ça les valait venez vous saluer mais à
une condition c'est quoi vous retiriez
l'insultent que vous avez adressés à ma
mère d'accès oui oui ça c'est vrai oui
j'en ai je voulais le hangar dont madame
messi lui verser ses d'expression aussi
bas les wii
arrêtez pas à l'organe aller voilà voilà
ça fait plaisir